the police are there to protect us
they're there for our safety now
occasionally there will be a bad apple
but my work with police has suggested
that that's a really exceptional the
problem is they have a gun so they could
do a lot of harm quickly
but that's overwhelmingly not the
problem the problem is the pressure that
police are under to make instant
decisions for safety for their safety
and the safety of others we all have bad
days we all have days or most of us
where we say I wish I hadn't said that I
wish I hadn't been so impatient this is
I was off today well if a policeman is
in that state and they're not any
different than the rest of us in that
regard it's a lot more dangerous so it's
a dangerous job that requires that
you're in a calm state of mind when you
go out to perform it and we have the
means to both assess that and further
that which is not deploying it
my biggest dream and I haven't yet been
able to convince any Police Department
to try this is to see whether we
couldn't have a really fast easy
technological assessment so before
someone goes out on the beat they sit
down and their heart rate blood pressure
skin conductance is monitored 5 or 10
seconds says yes you're in your normal
state go ahead and good luck or boy
you're very aroused today let's see if
we can do something to help you calm
down a bit before you go out on the job
we have the means to do that I believe
it could reduce some of the problems we
currently have because police are human
like everyone else all human beings have
bad days we need a way to be able
to specify this policeman self is a bad
day today let's see what we can do with
a few minutes of a few exercises to
bring him into a Commerce State so he go
out and do his job in a way he won't
regret